And you could just shut up with your dumbass victim blaming shit
because it's not. Choose a better partner.
Somebody doesn't walk up to you and say hey,
I'm gonna treat you like shit,
I'm gonna treat your kids like shit,
I'm gonna be the meanest fucking person you ever met.
I'm gonna fuck you in ways you never thought possible.
Nobody fucking says that. They're Mister Fucking Prince Charming.
They act like they're gonna do everything the world tells us.
No, no, no.
Girls mature faster than boys.
Just give him a minute, he'll grow into it.
Blah blah blah blah blah. This is some victim blaming shit.
And you sound like you're hurt as fuck on the inside.
So go do some fucking healing,
get some fucking therapy and leave the real shit,
the real life shit, to people with the
who actually fucking think and have some critical thinking skills.
Because this is just ugly.
Anytime you hear somebody victim blaming like this,
I will say it again. Choose a better partner.
Okay Mister Fucking anonymous.
Don't even have a picture,
no fucking videos posted.
Nothing to fucking show for your dumbass words.
Just go away, touch some fucking grass,
live some fucking life
and learn something before you fucking enter a conversation.